i'm iman shumpert we're here cuz i'm  your gift guys guidelines on how to do  this how to get it right how to put a  smile on somebody's face how to put a  fire in their heart so let's start off  the gift God with the John Geiger this  is the double-o tube you slip it on  conforms to your foot  gift I would get for myself it's  Invictus it's fresh its century and made  me feel like a champ get these for your  wife  Katie I see instant classic on be a lot  of ups and downs a lot of love the next  gift send a piece closer that's a nice  dice instead of the flowers it's all  about the presentation thumb the gears  of that friend that always on the  internet all sitting the bleachers don't  be the one on the field on the court or  some I got you got him on that was my  Holiday Gift Guide I hope you guys  enjoyed it and we here  [Music]